(audience applauding)
Hi, guys.
Thank you so much-
How's it going?
For doing this with us.
We are such barbecue fans here.
And I was just wondering if you guys could talk
about your experience as women in a field that's, you know,
been, sort of, categorically dominated by men,
but no longer.
So will you guys share that with me?
Well, for me, I grew up in a barbecue family.
So it's something that I'm used to
and it was always male-dominated.
And also for me, I just wanna, you know
I have two older brothers that are both in barbecue
and I just want to show 'em little sis
could do it better than they could.
(audience laughing)
Well, that, that is a healthy, competitive spirit.
I'm all for that.
Now, you guys sent us your brisket.
It is just the most insane-looking
piece of meat I've ever seen.
What is the biggest secret to making brisket?
Because it's such a staple in barbecue.
You know, I think it's patience, honestly.
And, I mean, we really focus on,
I mean, we really focus on the fires and then the,
of course, the cut of meat.
We use an all-natural brisket
which is very important to us.
And it comes from a happy farm.
The cows are humanely raised, no hormones, grass-fed.
And so, you can really taste the love
that the animals were given.
Well, I very much appreciate the humaneness
and the consciousness, conscientiousness of that answer.
And if you are interested in getting deeper
down the brisket rabbit hole with some of the very best
please go to our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and the ladies are gonna take you through
how to make their award-winning brisket.
Now, something that we can tackle here
on the show is the sides.
I am definitely salivating.
I don't know if you've heard this about me,
but, macaroni and cheese is, well, it's my happy place
and my downfall and everything in between.
Teach me the way ladies, teach me.
Got you.
Don't worry.
So we do a really nice kind of veggie mix
with tomatoes and poblanos and garlic,
and of course, jalapenos for that nice spice mix.
We bake it.
You know, just until the,
just until the veggies are tender
and then we will cool it down.
(air whooshing)
We are going to stick it right here in our blender.
By the way, what kind of blender are you using?
A Vitamix?
Of course.
Well, I actually am gonna send you a blender that has,
like, and I wanna know your thoughts.
Really?
I do.
I just made a blender and it's really a butt kicker.
So I'm excited for you ladies to tell me
if it measures up or not,
and you'll be, you have to be honest.
Oh, it looks great.
All right, are we ready?
All right.
So, let's blend it.
Are you ready?
(blenders whirring)
All right.
We got some melted cheese over here.
That in there.
Mix it up real good, so just meld it all together.
So you want it to get that nice color.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, uh-huh, I love it.
So, and you're gonna put some pepper in it.
And here at la Barbecue,
we use a ton of pepper.
And then you can add a little bit of salt
and that's just kind of like to your liking.
Yeah.
Just for a little bit of seasoning.
Then you're gonna add those shells and cheese.
We use shells because we really like
how the cheese kinda gets inside in it, and, you know,
holds all of that together.
You're just gonna kinda fold it all in
with that creamy bechamel.
And with magic, we have-
Oh my God.
Look at this.
This looks amazing.
Essentially what we're doing is making the sauce
and adding shells to it.
It looks amazing.
Okay, now, will you take me through...
(spoon clanging)
Oh, God.
(audience laughing)
Oh no.
I know, I can't help you.
I tried to cut myself off of this many, many times.
Okay, now, will you take me through the coleslaw?
Right now, we're gonna do our chipotle coleslaw.
This is our, just a different take on slaw.
It's a mayonnaise base.
We start with the green cabbage, red cabbage, and carrots.
From there, you're gonna add your mayo.
Oh, and then-
And then you're gonna add chipotle.
And you'd literally adjust to taste.
However spicy you wanna do it.
We do the granulated garlic.
Dust it on top.
There you're gonna add your paprika.
And to that another dusting.
And then again, heavy pepper.
And it's the coarse ground pepper
because it gives it that nice crunch.
And then the last one you wanna add is your salt to taste.
Now, is it okay if I taste this?
(laughing)
Absolutely.
(audience laughing)
Oh, my God.
You guys, this is incredible.
Holy cow!
This is from the chipotle?
Yes, you get a little bit of adobo and the chipotle.
Adobo!
Yes, I taste it.
Ha!
I love it, you guys, can't take on the spice.
(audience laughing)
Oh, my gosh.
You guys, you're both so talented and incredible.
And there's so much hype and fuss about you guys.
And I was so excited to meet you.
Thank you so much for having us.
I am so honored you came on the show
and watch your backs 'cause I am coming for you, ladies
Leanne and Ali,
(laughing)
of la Barbecue, the award-winning restaurant.
And all of your food trucks.
You're amazing.
(upbeat music)